rely on them if you're just joining us
on Al Jazeera live pictures from Beijing
there China and the world have just
found out who will be running the
country alongside president Xi Jinping
who as expected has been elected to
continue as the General Secretary of the
Communist Party Central Committee the
CPC Central Committee uh president XI is
going to lead the Communist party for an
unprecedented third term along here
alongside him uh six party members of
The polit Bureau the CPC Bureau have
been unveiled we saw them on stage with
President chiho later on introduced him
one by one let's bring in Patrick fork
in Beijing Forest who's following this
important event the Communist parties
Congress wrapping up this weekend and as
expected president XI being named as
Secretary General of the party for an
unprecedented third term tell us Patrick
about the lineup in the politburo
standing committee who's in who out and
what does it say about President Chief's
political strength and the direction in
which he wants to take China
well perhaps not much of a surprise
given yesterday's events but as we see
Charlie and Wong Hoon Nang along with
President Xi Jinping at the remaining
members from the previous politburo
standing committee but as I'd said just
a moment ago there was a lot of talk
about Lee Chang coming in in second
place so that means he is more or less
guaranteed to fill that role from Lika
Chang and become China's new premier of
course all these new roles won't be
confirmed until China's parliamentary
sessions in March and one of the things
about Lee Chang in particular that has
been noted is that he was not a vice
Premier before that as a break with
tradition but there is a possibility
that he may be appointed a vice Premier
between now and March to bring about
some continuation there there's also
notably a no place for huchenwa he was
another name that was talked about over
the course of this week and he was also
one of those people that perhaps wasn't
closely aligned with President Xi
Jinping there were people looking out
for his name today to see whether or not
there may be some balance to this Apollo
Bureau standing committee but this
really does seem to indicate that China
will really be going back to the one-man
dominance of Chinese politics president
XI here surrounded by close allies by
Loyalists and very little room for
others that may be seen as Rivals to him
and what was or what is the president's
message president xi's message as he
takes on this new term as the Communist
party's leader what direction does he
intend to take China
yeah well some interesting comments
there you know and he said that the uh
enormous task of the great Rejuvenation
of the Chinese Nation are going to be on
the shoulders of these seven men he
talked a lot about uh modernization of
China of course the previous goal was to
achieve moderate Prosperity but now the
goal up to 2049 is to make China a an
advanced economy and some would say uh a
global Supremacy and perhaps to overtake
the us as the number one superpower
there was an interesting nod in
particular to Marxist modernization
president Xi Jinping has regularly
talked about some sort of return to
Marxist roots and trying to develop
common Prosperity something that
certainly chimes with the people across
the country
economically there are going to be big
challenges ahead the Marxist ideology
has certainly been presented as an
alternative to Western capitalism thank
you for that Patrick fock live there in
Beijing